ich wende mich heute auf diesem
ungewöhnlichen weg an sie weil ich ihnen
sagen will was mich als bundeskanzlerin
und alle meine kollegen in der
bundesregierung in dieser situation
leitet deswegen lassen sie mich sagen es
ist ernst nehmen sie es auch ernst seit
der deutschen einheit
nein seit dem zweiten weltkrieg gab es
keine herausforderung an unser land mehr
bei der es so sehr auf unser gemeinsames
solidarisches handeln ankommt also es
geht darum das virus auf seinem weg
durch deutschland zu verlangsamen
und dabei müssen wir das ist
existenziell auf eines setzen
das öffentliche leben so weit es geht
herunterzufahren natürlich mit vernunft
und augenmaß
denn der staat wird weiter funktionieren
die versorgung wird selbstverständlich
weiter gesichert sein und wir wollen so
viel wirtschaftlicher tätigkeit wie
möglich bewahren und alle können sich
darauf verlassen dass die
lebensmittelversorgung jederzeit
gesichert ist und wenn regale einen tag
mal leer geräumt sind so werden sie
nachgefüllt jedem der in den
supermärkten unterwegs ist möchte ich
sagen vorratshaltung ist sinnvoll war es
im übrigen immer schon aber mit maß
hamstern als wäre es nie wieder etwas
geben ist sinnlos und letztlich
vollkommen und solidarisch ich
appelliere an sie halten sie sich an die
regeln
die nun für die nächste zeit gelten wir
werden als regierung stets neu prüfen
was sich wieder korrigieren lässt aber
auch was für möglich noch nötig ist
passen sie gut auf sich und auf ihre
liebsten auf ich danke ihnen